winter is coming and people are starting
to face consequences the laws of God and
men it would gone low-tech on this one
because I know I'm running behind if I
don't do it this way I'm afraid I'm not
gonna get it done at all this is easily
my favorite episode of the season so far
it's probably my favorite episode and
about a season and a half get maybe even
since season two I mean this is just an
amazing episode not just because of what
goes on and it also just how everything
is building house building on what came
before and how it's pointing towards
what's coming next we got our first look
at the iron bank which has been
mentioned before or mainly earlier in
this season but we finally get to go
there we get to see who these people are
and everyone seems slightly intimidated
by them and it you know that's rough
when you're just getting worse but when
you put Mark Gatiss doing his full
Mycroft Holmes again it you immediately
get okay yeah these guys yeah I don't
think you want to mess with them too
much we also get a nice little new side
to Davos The Onion Knight because we've
always been told he was a smuggler work
took pirates all of that but he's been
fairly noble in all the times that we've
seen him well now we get a little bit
more of a look at what life used to be
like for him and it's it's just fun you
may remember last time I said I was a
little bit concerned about what they
were doing with Daenerys because it felt
like a very artificial thing to just
keep her where she was long and keep her
from going to Westeros but this time
it's still the same stuff building off
what was done in the last episode but it
feels more earned it feels more real
because realistically what she's been
doing up to this point that she's just
she's just been a conqueror she's just
been rolling through accumulating forces
and just getting stronger getting more
powerful and just taking out people who
are in her way she hasn't really had to
rule up to this point well now she's
starting to see that it's one thing to
be a conqueror it's another thing to
actually rule over the lands once you've
conquered them and it's not as simple as
maybe she thought it was or assumed it
was or maybe she hadn't put that thought
into that side of it yet but now she's
finding out just how complicated all
this is and you start to wonder does she
still even want this maybe she does I
don't know she certainly has
right Justice Center that might keep her
going but you see you seeing her get
knocked down a pig a little bit and not
by you know someone coming in and giving
her scolding or some crap like that
she's just getting knocked out a pig by
life by the realities of life and it's
done really well we got a bit more time
with Theon whoo oh my god we knew he was
damaged I I think I didn't appreciate
the full extent of just how damaged he
is based on what he was put through in
the previous season oh god it's really
really really serious we get a little
more time with his sister to who was is
a badass you kind of expected that you
got that vibe off of her before but she
never got a really chance to see her in
action and confirmed that she is in fact
about as well confirmation made but all
that stuff good as it is that's all just
appetizers main course in this one
Tyrion goes on trial and it is so good
just the build-up to it and and who the
judges are and how the the crowd is
responding to what it is he's accused of
in the testimony that's being made in
who makes the testimony in what they say
and some of them giving outright lies
some of them telling the honest truth
but telling it without the context that
we know it actually happened and so it's
all just very damning I mean it's
handled like any good courtroom drama
really there are a lot of fantastic
moments over the course of this trial
and just lots of characters get lots of
little moments to shine I can't get too
much into details but Tywin Grimm get
some great stuff sort of behind the
scenes of what's going on and you just
you get that reminder of just how good
he is at figuring out how to get exactly
what he wants that means nobody's better
nobody's better than him at this and
Peter Dinklage as Tyrion he gets to show
a whole new side to Tyrion and it's
amazing to see cuz Tyrion one of Tyrians
main sort of features is that he's
always been very collected very calm
even in situations where his life has
been in dire danger he's always just
been fairly you know he'll have little
moments of melancholy he's even gotten
mad a few times they'll usually driven
by a little bit of drink and that's just
sort of been
even in those moments he keeps himself
fairly collected not this time to just
see him unleash at these people I mean
not physically but just see him unload
and just go after them and let them know
exactly what it is that he has been
keeping the thoughts within his head he
just lets some flow and it's it's
amazing he's so good and then the capper
this episode setting up what's gonna
happen in the next episode it's just so
perfect like I said favorite episode of
the season easily so let me ask you this
this is sort of a more of an overarching
question where most of the times I am
just asking somebody specifically this
episode of the characters currently
alive and vying for some sort of
position of power who do you think would
actually be best served by ending up on
the Iron Throne not necessarily who
deserves it more who has the birthright
to it but who do you think would
actually be a decent ruler who is who is
a viable option to be sitting there drop
something down to the comments let's
talk about it and until next time this
council is adjourned